are we finally going to get a reboot of
the six million dollar man
welcome to sidetrek your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
[Music]
so since 2015 mark wahlberg has been
signed on to produce and starring the
six billion dollar man a reboot of the
original lee majors tv series
now personally i can't wait for this
it's been put back over and over again
peter berg a regular collaborator with
mark wahlberg left the project really
early on there's been multiple script
rewrites and i'm sure covert has slowed
things down as well but mark wahlberg
keeps talking about it he keeps pushing
it and it looks like it's going to
happen
travis knight has now signed on as the
director following his success of
bumblebee and has a good working
relationship with mark wahlberg already
so it looks like this is in now in
pre-production and actually could start
filming anytime potentially by the
summer
but what can we expect from this new
movie this 6 billion dollar man the
original book by martin kaden back in
1972 called the cyborg was slightly
darker and more gritty than the version
we then got on tv screens in 1973
starring lee mages
the glennae larsen effect of the tv
series made that he didn't really kill
anyone and nobody really got hurt as
normal for those sort of tv shows
remember the 18 bullets flying
everywhere nobody even got a scratch
well i don't think we'll get that in the
mark wahlberg version i could see this
being far more like the original book
where steve austin's character would
actually kill people wherever necessary
to fulfill the mission and didn't really
have any remorse he was far more robotic
in his way of dealing with the job at
hand
even though the tv series shared many of
the quite dark moments of the book like
steve austin's early attempt to commit
suicide as he tried to come to terms
with what had happened to him
it did lack some of the grittiness like
i say
his more
robotic nature that was trying to
reflect in the book that they didn't
really try to convey in the series
now i think the relationship between
technology and man is different today
than it was when this series was first
produced
we actually have a far closer
relationship with technology today and
certain technologies like the advances
in prosthetics and so the work elon musk
is doing to create neural links he
actually wants to plug our brains
directly into technology
means that this relationship is going to
get more and more complicated as time
goes by
we as a culture still today struggle
with catching up with the internet and
modern technologies it advances every
single day and this mark wahlberg movie
if i was producing it would reflect that
on our relationship with technology and
how do we
cope with it
but mentioning the technology and how
it's advanced will we see the robotic
legs that he can do 60 miles an hour and
strength of a bulldozer in their robotic
eye like we saw in the original series
i don't think there'd be much reason to
change it a great deal in fact it made
it more realistic today because those
technologies are reasonably close to
reality it was only about a week ago
that a lady had the first prosthetic
eyeball
an eyeball that actually is giving her
some limited vision
this technology is actually on the cusp
of becoming reality so they would only
have to push that envelope to its
maximum for it to be still a realistic
science fiction tv show even if you
can't see miles with his eyeball or as
long as they don't start having laser
beams or anything like they did in some
of the comics it's
going to be a very realistic sci-fi show
as i say in the book and the tv series
with lee mages he was always kind of a
reluctant spy he never really wanted to
be a spy and he was sort of forced into
it by the oso and the osi i'm certainly
reflect that again in the new film
because it makes it a far more
interesting character and gives depth to
his character that he doesn't want to be
doing this and working for the
government the way he is but at the same
time he is a patriot and he will do what
is necessary
also the geopolitical landscape that we
live in today means that there are loads
of stories that they could explore
and the war on terror the thing for isis
uh complicated relationship with china
and russia means that there are lots of
things that
our steve austin could be keeping
himself busy with
but i do think this is an opportunity in
this film to explore as i say the
relationship we have with technology
today
it's a complicated relationship we have
already and this could be reflected in
the internal turmoil of steve austin
himself trying to contemplate what
basically is done to him after the
accident which meant that he had to have
an arm two legs and an eyeball replaced
there's also the opportunity to again if
they have this neural link technology
that elon musk is working on today
is it steve austin's brain or is it the
technology similar to sort of doc ock in
the spiderman movies or the more recent
robocop terrible movie that they made
that the robot can actually take over
the human side and take control
could that also be a problem for steve
austin are we ever going to be really
sure when he acts the way he does
whether it's the programming or the man
now it won't be a shock if this never
happens they've been trying to reboot
the six million dollar man for years it
was 2011 when kevin smith's um
unproduced script got turned into a
comic book with dynamite comics in 2014
dynamite comics went on to do a series
six comic as well which followed on from
the original tv series
both comics were very popular and really
lead on to why this series is still
popular today and we still all know
about lee mages and the slow motion
running and all that sort of thing that
is one risk for this film actually i
don't want to see them sort of making
fun of that too much if they have one
little joke about it that'll be okay
but i remember sort of when they did the
thunderbirds movie a few years ago the
live action i don't know if you remember
that and they sort of actually had the
actors sort of going
it was just stupid and it kind of ruined
the film um i don't think mark wahlberg
is stupid enough to do that but if they
try to have tongue in cheek fun or poke
fun at the original tv series too much
it's going to ruin the movie
so what do i actually think is this
going to happen
it is still in pre-production but it's
been in pre-production for seven
years
mark wahlberg does have other projects
on the go as well
it's been a decade since the first sort
of script was produced by kevin smith
that they tried to produce
so
i think this will happen
but i won't hold my breath
and if i was a betting man i wouldn't
put a lot of money on it
so what do you think do you want to see
the 6 billion man on our tv screens
will it be released at the cinema or
will it just go straight to amazon like
i suspect it might if you do see it what
sort of story do you want to see do you
want to see something with a bit of fun
or do you want to see something that's a
bit darker and gritty please leave a
comment tell me what you think
if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps us out and
you can for a small fee join the channel
and become a side tracker and help me
produce more content so please hit the
join button also you can join us on
facebook there is a link in the
description as always guys please stay
safe and i'll see you very soon
[Music]
you